the former French president Jacques
Chirac has died
he served twice as Prime Minister before
becoming president in 1995 and served
until 2007 in a statement his son-in-law
said he died surrounded by his family
peacefully he was 86 years old Natasha
Butler joins me now live from Paris and
Natasha eject she is one of these names
we always tend to associate with France
and the French presidency and he had
quite an impact on the country he led
for so long well that's right I think
it's fair to say the JAC Chirac is one
of France's most famous politicians and
he certainly had an incredibly
impressive career by any standards he
served twice as president of France
twice as Prime Minister he served as a
minister in various governments and he
was also the mayor of Paris for 18 years
which is a very prestigious job here in
France so he's somebody who managed to
stay in one office or another for a very
long time and that is why so many people
in France so many different generations
know Jacques Chirac now it was known
that he'd been ill for some time his
family have certainly been quite
secretive about the state of his health
over the past years and there have been
rumors about his death in the past but
it does seem but now according to his
family members Jacques Chirac
has died he was 86 years old and he will
be remembered by many people in France
not just as the sort of consummate
politician but also as someone who was
believed and described I should say by
friends and colleagues are something of
a bovie very charmer he certainly had
the people's touch and that is perhaps
why he managed to have so many different
political jobs for so long it's the this
news has been has just dropped in the
last sort of 30 minutes or so we're
already getting some reaction as Jean
Claude Younker has announced that he is
moved and devastated by sheer acts a
death and as you were saying there in
the Sante he did he was held in quite
high as
by the the French despite some of the
the political troubles he had later in
life yeah that's right because he had
this long this lengthy political career
in France but there were always rumors
and during that career that of
corruption or various wrongdoing and it
was after he ended his last presidential
term that Jacques Chirac was actually
found guilty of corruption in relation
to his time in office as mayor of Paris
and that is something the sonne
overshadowed this very long and well
highly esteemed career he also was
somebody that had ties with many African
leaders and created something that's
called France a fake this kind of sense
of this strong tie between France and
some of its former colonies in Africa
and although some of those ties were
seen as being constructive there were
also questions about exactly what they
were and powerjack sure acts closeness
to some leaders that were seen as
dictators in Africa so that was
certainly something that overshadowed
his time but he certainly somebody who
put France on the international stage as
he liked and he liked to push France as
a leader in international affairs and
you might remember in 2003 it was
Jacques Chirac who opposed the us-led
invasion of Iraq and really France
became a voice against military action
at the time he certainly did well as we
see that news just coming to us in the
last 30 minutes or so I'm sure we'll be
crossing back to you and it's Asha
Butler throughout the day but for now
thank you very much indeed for bringing
us the latest